From this distance vantage point might,
let's see him have any particular
interest,
but for us it's different.
Consider again that dot that's here.
That's home.
That's us on it.
Everyone you love,
everyone you know,
everyone you ever heard of,
every human being who ever was lived out
their lives,
the aggregate or joy and suffering.
Thousands of confident religions,
ideologies and economic doctrines.
Every hunter and forager,
every hero and coward,
every Creator and destroyer of
civilization,
every Kenyan peasant,
every young couple in love,
every mother and father,
hopeful child,
inventor and explorer.
Every teacher of morals,
corrupt politician,
every superstar,
every supreme leader,
every saint and sinner in the history of
our species lived there on the dust
suspended in a sunbeam.
The earth is a very small stage in a
fast cosmic arena.
Think of the rivers of blood spilled by
all those generals and emperors so that
in glorious triumph they could become
the momentary masters of a fraction of a
dot.
Think of the endless cruelties visited
by the inhabitants of one corner of this
pixel on the scarcely distinguishable
inhabitants of some other corner.
How frequent their misunderstanding,
how eager they are to kill one another.
How fervent their hatreds,
our posturings,
our imagined self importance.
The delusion that we have some
privileged position in the universe are
challenged by this point of Pale light.
Our planet.
He's a luminary Spec in the great
enveloping cosmic dark,
you know,
are obscurity in all this vastness.
There is no hint that help will come
from elsewhere to save us from
ourselves.
The earth is the only world known so far
to harbor life.
There is nowhere else,
at least in the near future to which our
species could migrate.
Visit,
yes,
settle.
Not yet like it or not.
For the moment,
the earth is where we make our stand.
It has been said that astronomy is a
humbling and character building
experience.
There is perhaps no better demonstration
of the folly of human conceits.
Then this distance image of our tiny
world,
to me,
it underscores our responsibility to
deal more kindly with one another and to
preserve and cherish the pale blue dot.
The only home we've ever known him.